holy cow
not ather the building has been blown
away this is a scene from one of the
United States deadliest domestic attacks
as we walked up I could not believe what
was happening it really couldn't believe
your eyes and you especially couldn't
believe that it was actually happening
here in Oklahoma City the bombing in
Oklahoma City was an attack on innocent
children and defenseless citizens the
attack came without warning and
according to a US government source told
CBS news that it has middle-east
terrorism written all over it but it
wasn't some foreign agent that killed
168 adults and children this was the
result of homegrown right-wing extremism
well am I in my pure evil and by the
face of terror sitting here in front of
you the Oklahoma City bombing happened
years before the Charlottesville
Virginia attack
both assaults are examples of the United
States long-running struggle with
right-wing extremism and brutality hey
fam I me Mayan in part 1 of our series
we took a look at the rise of right-wing
fanaticism in the United States and the
government's response to it today I'm
standing at a memorial dedicated to the
victims of the Oklahoma City bombing to
find out what this disaster can teach us
about our future
[Music]
this is Oklahoma
cat-boy country's the birthplace of the
legendary Mickey Mantle and the location
of the country's deadliest domestic
attack committed by one of its own
basically there are four elements that I
have to
information regarding
[Music]
it's been 24 years since a moving truck
filled with explosives park near Federal
Building in Oklahoma City destroying it
and devastating a nation
the explosion killed 168 people
including small children and injured 500
more the blast was catastrophic half of
the nine story federal building
collapsed into the street an estimated
900 people inside this attack is one
type of far-right
extremism which generally falls into two
categories hate based like the neo-nazis
or white nationalist as we discussed in
part 1 of our series an anti-government
like the men responsible for the
Oklahoma City bombing these are the
names of the survivors of the attack
that happened at 9:02 a.m. on April 19th
1995 Dennis Purefoy is one of those
survivors and we're on our way to meet
him
so this is where I was sitting the
building as you can see here and one
time I figured I was a 115 feet from the
bombing
that's so close to you girl that is so
close
here's how purifies office looked before
the explosion look at the date on this
photo it was taken only a few weeks
before the disaster this is what Purefoy
office building looked like after a
massive truck bomb blasted off the
facade of a building with a daycare
center instantly killing a hundred
people and trapping dozens more beneath
rubble I saw a flash and I don't know if
it was a reflection on the computer
screen of the actual explosion or if it
was an electrical spark everything went
totally dark and I was knocked out of my
chair that's seemed to all happen at
once a ceiling tile fell on Purefoy
trapping him a co-worker helped him
escape he suffered no major injuries and
along with a few colleagues got to a
place where they could get help
in the immediate aftermath of the
bombing there were two searches one for
the missing this is Elijah the end these
two is necessarily is five and one for
the assailants
it was several days before I started
even paying attention to who's supposed
to suspects were and that kind of thing
I was going to hospital as we're
coworkers were then after a few now you
started going to funerals
I have the obits I think for all of my
co-workers in here how hard was it to go
to all of those funerals well I was a
something art I really wanted to do I
wanted to be in everyone one of the
reason that it was hard is that there
were sometimes multiple ones on the same
day the earliest news coverage quickly
speculated so called Middle Eastern
terrorism but the Bombers weren't a
group of brown people from far-off
places they were homegrown far-right
militants motivated by their hatred of
the federal government this is what the
Bombers actually looked like I think I
was kind of in shock like most people
were what what would possess Timothy
McVeigh who was an Army veteran why
would he do such a thing
and this was during a period where the
US had seen several violent far-right
acts the bombing attack shares the same
date as the Waco Siege and Olympic
bomber Eric Rudolph planted an explosive
at the Atlanta Games in 1996 the news
media failed to link these stories in
the same way they so eagerly do with
so-called Islamic extremist acts how
much did you know about far-right
extremism before Oklahoma City really
nothing I hadn't paid attention to it
hadn't been been in the news before the
bombing I really didn't know the extent
of far-right extremists around the
country once I became aware of it I
tried to let other people know I talked
about it I talked about it at church I
didn't I don't know that I was on a
crusade but I was definitely interested
in more people learning about it and
being aware about it the plot Timothy
McVeigh and Terry Nichols concocted is
eerily similar to one that a trio of
white men had hoped to execute the day
after the 2016 presidential election in
Garden City Kansas the militiamen who
dubbed themselves the Crusaders schemed
to kill as many Somali refugees as
possible by detonating four car bombs
outside an apartment complex that also
doubled as a mosque they were planning
to blow up this community in Garden City
with Timothy McVeigh style truck bombs
situate themselves at the exits to the
community with machine guns and shoot
anybody who tried to flee so it was
gonna be a horrible massacre this is
David and I work and the reason he knows
so much about what happened in Kansas is
because he's been studying far-right
extremism in the US since the 1970s
a judge sentenced those three Kansas men
to 25 to 30 years in jail and their plot
shows something neither says the nation
has forgotten people understood prayer
to 9/11 that terrorism could take
variety of shapes after 9/11 the only
kind of terrorism that people thought of
were essentially Arabs today we've had a
national tragedy two airplanes have
crashed into the World Trade Center in
an apparent terrorist attack on our
country
[Applause]
Busch's focus was on threats coming from
overseas his so-called war on terror
didn't address far-right figures like
Bay Nichols or Rudolph but we're gonna
smoke them out our mission is to battle
terrorism and to join with freedom
loving people this is a long-term battle
war and while President Bush literally
said Islam is peace to make a
distinction between religion and acts of
terror the country's focus on Iraq and
Afghanistan meant that the far-right
threat that so recently had its
attention faded from its collective
memory while the United States was
focused on al-qaeda and Muslims
far-right hate was organizing and
energizing unfortunately America a lot
of times our legislators and even law
enforcement to some degree are reactive
something significant has to happen in
order for people to actually do
something about the problem former
Department of Homeland Security analyst
Darrell Johnson watched as far-right
extremism became a bigger threat to the
country particularly after Donald Trump
was elected so typically during
Democratic administrations like Obama
administration Clinton administration we
see a rise of the far right and then
typically during Republican
administration we see just the opposite
but this time in 2016 we had a
Republican administration coming to
power and the far right has continued to
operate at a heightened level which goes
against all the trending that I've seen
over the past you know 30 to 40 years
Johnson and I were both believed the
president's heated rhetoric has
mainstreamed extremist messages and I
word says President Trump has soft-pedal
a version of white nationalism and made
it more palatable for a wider audience
the people who were committing these
crimes are either referencing Trump's
name
like shouting Trump Trump Trump as they
beat people up or threaten people or
using his name to say you know will
Trump's going to get you out of here
this problem didn't start with Donald
Trump he took advantage of it
but he definitely fueled it and it's
massively expanded because of his
presidency and yes we will build the
wall we've already started planning it
will be built
[Music]
nayad says there's a threat he's seen
connect the philosophy of pharma
extremism to its believers the
personality type is drawn to these
movements consistently is what we call
right-wing authoritarians authoritarian
personalities are basically people who
want to be told what to do people who
want an authoritarian rule because they
feel more safe and secure this is the
role the Trump plays this isn't the
first time that this has happened the
country's history is littered with
examples of far-right extremism being
overlooked ignored and sometimes even
being turned into government policy
think of all the violence associated
with Jim Crow how worried are you that
people will forget Oklahoma City that
it'll fade from the memories I think as
time goes on it will start fading from
memory a little bit
but it is it's still even to this day
it's the largest domestic terrorism as
far as a number of casualties in the
United States
I hope that we remain for many years to
come
the still the largest domestic terrorism
incident in our history we can't anymore
just say it's not my business like I I
can't pay attention to all that it is
our business we have to pay attention to
it right now the nation is out of place
where it's been before and confronting
right-wing fanaticism and it's making
some of the same decisions it's made
before in governmental policies and in
news coverage see the governmental
response isn't the only thing
contributing to this problem the news
media they have culpability to both pure
for and I would say part of the reason
people don't see Pharma extremism as a
threat is because of how the news media
has and continues to portray it I think
I think they should report more in depth
so unless you get unless than the media
provides to some background people
really do remain like pretty much
ignorant about it the book that inspired
Timothy McVeigh it's been inciting
far-right violence for decades Timothy
McVeigh he would try to convince people
for months and months and months his
circle of friends he tried to convince
him he tried to get him to read the
Turner Diaries and stuff like that the
Turner Diaries is a racist dystopian
novel written by a neo-nazi leader the
book reached the pinnacle of its
popularity in 1995 once a connection to
Timothy McVeigh was made but there's
something 1995 didn't have which may
have limited its reach widespread
high-speed Internet the internet and
social media revolutionized how
right-wing extremism met grew and
conspired and that's really important
because not all right wing extremism is
created
it can be found in even the most liberal
of places
[Music]
there's people you won't know you're
trained to blend in with your community
[Applause]
hey fam thanks so much for watching
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
one of the things that was the most
intriguing to me at the Oklahoma City
memorial were the two gates that they
have there's one at 901 symbolizing the
city's innocence before the bombing and
then there's a gate symbolizing 903 one
minute after the bombing and what
happens to Oklahoma City afterward be
sure to stay tuned for the third and
final part of our series and we'll see
you next time thanks for watching
[Music]